tous
jean paul ii à strasbourg ce soir le
pape s'adresse aux jeunes européens en
direct dans ce journal
fin de la grève des gardiens de prisons
accords signés aujourd'hui mais
poursuite du conflit des infirmières qui
arrêteront de nouveau le travail la
semaine prochaine un document
exceptionnel la patrouille de france but
de l'intérieur comme si vous y étiez
comme si vous étiez l'un des pilotes
demain cette patrouille fête ses 35 ans
passés dans le ciel madame monsieur
bonsoir
strasbourg capitale de l'europe et
villes françaises c'est sous ce double
signe que jean paul ii a placé son
quatrième voyage en territoire français
en effet le pape pendant son séjour de
quatre jours en alsace lorraine évoquera
à la fois les problèmes de l'église
catholique au niveau européen sans
négliger le contact avec elles et trois
importantes communautés religieuses de
cette région d'alsace lorraine
catholique bien sûr mais aussi
protestante et juive
jean paul ii est depuis ce matin à
strasbourg où il a été accueilli par le
président de la république monsieur
françois mitterrand et il termine cette
première journée par une rencontre en ce
moment même avec les jeunes européens au
stade de la meinau toujours à strasbourg
bien entendu françois korber le
reportage de françois cornut chacune
vrai que nous avons un petit problème
bien alors je crois que nous avons un
petit problème avec ce reportage de
l'arrivée de jean paul ii nous y
reviendrons tout à l'heure pas de
problème nous allons tout de suite
rejoindre en direct maintenant
jean-claude d'arrigo qui se trouve
justement au stade de la meinau où le
pape jean paul ii est en train de
s'exprimer en ce moment-même dont
jean-claude oui je vous entends d'année
pour écouter le pape vient de terminer
la première partie de cette rencontre de
ce soir est de faire réfléchir les
jeunes sur un certain nombre de
problèmes qu'ils ont évoqué leurs
difficultés de vivre leurs difficultés
de se rencontrer leurs difficultés de
trouver du travail
mais pour pouvoir nous aider à mieux
réfléchir sur l'importance de cette
soirée jet à côté de moi le cardinal
jean marie lustiger qui pourra nous dire
comment il réagit face à l'enthousiasmé
extraordinaire de ces jeunes bien une
phase plus je suis stupéfait par ce que
il ya là des jeunes de l'europe entière
ce sont des jeunes comme les autres et
les questions qui sont en train de poser
au pape qu'ils ont déjà posé auparavant
sont des questions stupéfiante
pardonnez-moi de désespoir car au fond
il le crash il recrache toute la misère
du monde que qu'on cesse de de leur
donner de leur montrer par par toutes
les images du monde qu'on leur donne et
la réponse du pape ce qu'il ya de tout à
fait étonnant c'est une réponse
apparemment sable très simple positive
optimiste ou seguin et s'il y croit
ce n'est pas parce que c'est des paroles
naïves et parce qu'ils sentent que ce
que le pape l'ordi repose sur une force
spirituelle extraordinaire il ya là des
jeunes qui ne sont pas tous catholiques
et le dernier mot du papa était jésus
christ et le stade applaudi a crié de
joie en entendant ce mot
au fond ce qu'il manque à ces jeunes
c'est sur quoi appuyer une certitude
désespoir ou espoirs la jeunesse est là
au mieux au milieu de ça rien vous dire
est ce qu'ils sont représentatifs de la
jeunesse européenne ces jeunes je n'en
sais absolument rien j'ai été faire un
petit tour ya tout ça va j'ai été trop
longtemps aumônier des étudiants pour
savoir que chaque jeune est
et il n'y a pas une jeunesse il ya des
jeunes moi c'est ma conviction bien
jean-claude à rigaud grignan lustiger
merci en tout cas d' à vous de vous être
ajoutée à nos envoyés spéciaux qui se
trouve au stade de la meinau ce soir à
strasbourg
c'était parfait pour un banc d'essai
monseigneur merci à vous en tout cas de
vous être ajoutés à notre liste de
reporter on va retourner maintenant à
cette journée dont je vous parlais juste
avant que monseigneur lustiger
n'intervienne
donc je reviens sur le démarrage de
cette journée ce matin le pape jean paul
ii arrive à strasbourg il est accueilli
par le président de la république
monsieur françois mitterrand et il
arrive donc ce soir vous l'avez vu au
stade de la meinau à strasbourg
reportage de françois korber je suis
l'ami des jeunes mais je demeure un ami
exigeant et n'attendez pas de moi une
solution technique à chacune de vos
attentes
il n'y a pas de solution miracle même le
pape n'en a pas
cette rencontre à strasbourg avec les
jeunes de l'europe jean paul ii l'a
voulu ils sont aussi venus d'italie
d'allemagne d'angleterre d'espagne et du
portugal pour dire au pape leurs
espérances mais aussi leurs angoisses
je vais saluer de tout mon coeur que
c'est qu'ils sont venus et en même temps
tous et il ne pouvait pas venir
il n'y a pas deux sortes de jeunesse
celles qui croient et celles qui ne
croient pas en exprimer les jeunes au
stade de la meinau
au cours de leur jeu scénique elle nous
saint père a trouvé les réponses selon
son habitude le pape à la meinau comme
ailleurs ne mâchera pas ses mots en
s'adressant passé quarante mille jeunes
européens avant sa rencontre avec les
jeunes le pape avait célébré la messe
dans la cathédrale de strasbourg
première étape véritablement religieuse
de son voyage en alsace lorraine
il
la matinée pour jean paul ii a d'abord
été diplomatique et politique au conseil
de l'europe qui avait demandé à de
recevoir le pape a rappelé que les
racines du continent européen et est
indissolublement liés à la culture
chrétienne dans monsieur si l'euro peut
être fidèle à elle même
il faut qu'elle sache rassembler toutes
les forces vives de ce continent en
respectant le caractère original chaque
région
mais en retrouvant dans ses racines un
esprit commun au palais des droits de
l'homme la phrase clé de jean paul ii a
été il ne saurait y avoir de droit pour
l'homme s'il n'y a pas de droits pour
dieu de l'europe
on parlera souvent durant ces quatre
jours c'est le président mitterrand
lui-même qui a donné le ton ce matin en
accueillant jean paul ii à l'aéroport de
strasbourg-entzheim
tout se tient sur nos étroites planète
la construction communautaire qui pierre
à pierre s'édifie est d'abord à
strasbourg sa capitale dessine les
fondements d'une oeuvre plus vaste
encore
voilà donc pour cette première partie de
du voyage de jean-paul ii en alsace
lorraine alors contrairement à la foi
qui anime les pays d'amérique latine ou
du tiers-monde lorsqu'il les visites et
bien dans les pays riches d'europe comme
le nôtre jean paul ii et l'église
catholique se trouve confronté à la
crise d'espérance comme le disait
monseigneur lustiger tout à leur crise
des religions à cet égard le témoignage
qui vient de paraître aux éditions plon
d'un curé de campagne le père bernard
alexandre est très instructif cet homme
est depuis 43 ans curé en normandie il a
vu changer sa profession entre
guillemets ses fils elle également
en même temps qu évoluer la société
française valérie fournier ou pascal
puis l'église y ait une curée de
campagne
aujourd'hui dans la solitude avec
fidélité dévouement l'abbé alexandre
tente inlassablement depuis 43 ans de
faire entendre la parole du christ
le curé tel qu'on l'imaginé autrefois en
soutane faire enfermer dans un
presbytère toujours à la disposition de
ses paroissiens comme la pompe à
incendie
j'ai fini devenu un étranger pour ses
paroissiens le prêtre français
vieillissent la relève ne vient pas
c'est la crise de la vocation
je pense que l'église reste trop repliée
sur elle même je vais tous les propos
que l'on peut entendre de ci de là n est
pas dans la vie tant qu'elle ne sera pas
dans la vie ne pourra pas jouer sa
mission si le climat change si le statut
du prêt de l'état devrait enfin
pratiquer vivant show modifie est
certain que des jeunes auront la
vocation
on l'a trop qu'elle prête on nous a
ordonné pour s'entraîner les ventes fil
pour prêcher l'évangile est en fait nous
a mis dans de telles conditions
paroissiale qu'en fait il n'était pas
possible de près c'est vraiment
l'évangile de christ a dit si vous
n'êtes pas reçu dans une commune ou dans
une dans un village et bien secoué la
sandale de vos souliers et partez le
catholique français ne remets que 12
francs par an au denier du culte
l'église de france devient pauvre
d'argent de prêtres et de fidèles
l'actualité sociale maintenant le
conflit des gardiens de prison se
termine celui des infirmières se durcit
au contraire ce sont les deux
informations sociales de ce samedi pour
les gardiens de prisons d'abord tous les
syndicats exception faite de la cgt
minoritaire il faut le signaler ont
signé un accord avec le gouvernement
le travail doit reprendre normalement
demain midi dans toutes les prisons
françaises pascal deschamps fatigués
mais heureux
gilbert bonnemaison après toute une nuit
de négociations il était dès 10 heures
ce matin dans le bureau du premier
ministre
avec le garde des sceaux son protocole
d'accord sous le bras 470 postes créés
40 millions de francs pour améliorer
l'ordinaire des gardiens et 300 francs
d'augmentation un résultat jugé
important tant les syndicats signataires
bien que n'y figurent pas l'abaissement
de l'âge de la retraite pouvait pas se
permettre de rester figé
ça faisait le onzième jour de grève et
nous avons obtenu sur d'autres points
des avancées importantes la cgt qui a
recueilli 12 % des voix aux dernières
élections professionnelles a refusé de
signer le protocole pour elle il y
manque l'essentiel vous est impossible
de notre signature sans la mesure que
les pénitentiaire demandait sur
l'avancement de l'âge de la retraite qui
était considéré par les personnels comme
le seul geste possible de reconnaissance
de leur rôle social
les gardiens de la prison de la santé à
paris qui avait décidé ce matin de
poursuivre la grève ont finalement voté
la reprise du travail il y à quelques
heures l'inconnue subsistent encore pour
une demi douzaine d'établissements en
province où les discussions se
poursuivent en tout cas demain à midi ce
sont des centaines de détenus qui
quitteront les commissariats transformé
pendant 11 jours en maison d'arrêt
provisoire pour prendre le chemin des
prisons compte tenu de ce qui a été
obtenu par les syndicats que vous venez
d'entendre dans certaines prisons comme
celle de la santé à paris donc les
gardiens ont un peu traîné les pieds
avant de décider de se décider à
reprendre le travail mais dans
l'ensemble accord est plutôt bien
accueillie comme le prouvent ces
réactions recueillies cet après midi à
la prison des baumettes où avait démarré
le conflit il faut s'en souvenir
stéphane magnier des piquets de grève
devant la prison des baumettes
il ne reste plus cet après midi que des
banderoles délaissé dell annonce du
protocole d'accord ce matin les
grévistes avaient décidé de rentrer chez
eux
laissant le franchissement de la porte
libre à la grande joie des avocats qui
attendait cela depuis plus de dix jours
mais aussi des familles des internés
visiblement soulagé de constater ce qui
ressemblait un retour à la normale ce
n'est que peu à peu dans le courant de
l'après-midi par petits groupes que les
gardiens se retrouvait devant la porte
pour qu'augmenter les documents expédier
des centrales syndicales par télex et
envisager la suite à donner à leur
mouvement
la maison d'arrêt des baumettes le
suspens dans ce style de mouvements
blocage des et gros par leurs avocats
mais nous continuons à l'action à
l'intérieur
bourreau mettre en place un peu tout un
système qui a été un peu délaissé par la
direction et sa politique
nous voulons reprendre nous surveillant
les rênes et surtout notre identité
faire notre travail consciencieusement
et donnent de bonnes conditions
beaucoup de grévistes n'envisagent
toutefois la reprise que du bout des
lèvres
certes il ya eu en partie satisfaction
sur les salaires mais blocage sur la
retraite l'intersyndicale est en cours
de réunions à cette heure ci c'est elle
qui décidera si la prison à l'origine du
mouvement est durablement retourner au
calme dossier réglé pour les gardiens de
prison donc en revanche le conflit des
infirmières se durcit les négociations
avec les syndicats ne reprendront que
lundi prochain une grève est prévue
d'ores et déjà pour jeudi prochain 13
octobre mais le plus important
aujourd'hui c'est qu'en dehors des
syndicats sophie ciel qui ne sont que
partiellement représentatif il faut le
signaler dans cette corporation
la coordination parisienne des
infirmières s'est transformée
aujourd'hui en coordination nationale et
appellent à cesser le travail dès lundi
d'ailleurs dans certains établissements
la grève n'avait jamais réellement cessé
françois jeu
le plus important service des urgences
de paris l'hôtel dieu
cet après-midi des malades et accidentés
sont hospitalisés aussitôt admis ils
sont prises en charge par des infirmiers
des infirmières en grève
réquisitionnés car aujourd'hui dans cet
hôpital la grève continue et c'est au
moins le cas dans plusieurs
établissements de la région parisienne
une grève spontanée alors que ni les
syndicats ni la coordination n'avait
appelé aujourd'hui à la poursuite du
mouvement ne sont pas du tout décidés à
arrêter un mouvement qui est
effectivement très important parce que
nous n'avons rien eu des infirmiers
infirmières très mobilisés qui se sont
réunis en coordination nationale toute
la journée à la sorbonne
là on a décidé de reconduire la grève à
partir de lundi
autre décision une manifestation
nationale jeudi à paris un mouvement des
infirmières qui revendique toujours son
autonomie par rapport aux syndicats et
qui demandent plus que jamais à être
reconnue par les pouvoirs publics
aujourd'hui
et que la profession infirmière n'est
pas syndiquée pratiquement pas donc
seuls moyens d'existence aujourd'hui et
à travers de cette coordination donc les
moyens de prouver aujourd'hui ça va être
court sur le plan national
arrivé à déterminer quelle est
réellement notre représentativité
ce sera pas blanche
pour finir au niveau des fédérations
syndicales et pour le gouvernement
enfin lundi les négociations reprennent
entre les syndicats et le ministre de la
santé claude evin le gouvernement qui a
débloqué jeudi dernier un milliard de
francs pour cette profession encore fait
quelques propositions hier mais des
propositions jugées toujours très
insatisfaisante par les syndicats et les
infirmières oui et cette coordination
des infirmières fait école puisque ce
soir on parle de la constitution de
coordination des infirmières
anesthésistes ou encore des personnels
soignants aides-soignantes et puis aussi
des personnels ouvriers des
établissements hospitaliers
on avait jusqu'à présent c'est vrai peu
entendu le ministre de la santé monsieur
et 20 sur ce sujet il s'est exprimé sur
l'antenne d'une radio locale pacifique
fm un entretien qui sera diffusé demain
dimanche matin en avant première voici
ce que dit le ministre aux infirmières
en substance vous n'êtes pas seuls au
monde vous faites partie de la fonction
publique et dans ce cas certaines choses
sont possibles d'autres noms écoutons le
les infirmières avaient en effet un
retard les propositions que nous avons
formulées permettent de rattraper ce
retard
c'est vrai que cela ne correspond pas à
ce qu'elle estimerait elle être juste et
la justice ne s'apprécient pas
uniquement par rapport aux infirmières
elle s'apprécie aussi par rapport à
l'ensemble des professions qui sont dans
le secteur public et dans le cas de ce
statut après les gardiens de prison donc
les infirmières de nouveaux troubles se
profile à l'horizon dans l'éducation
nationale le cnes syndicat le snes
plutôt syndicat national du second degré
lance un ultimatum au gouvernement et
menace d'arrêt de travail si rien n'est
fait pour éviter la dégradation du
pouvoir d'achat et des conditions de
travail des enseignants
la politique maintenant le front
national de jean marie le pen était
réunie aujourd'hui à paris pour lancer
sa campagne du non au référendum sur la
nouvelle calédonie mais il y avait aussi
du changement dans l'air au niveau de la
direction du parti après les résultats
des élections cantonales
cosic à jean marie le pen et ses amis
n'aiment pas les situations en demi
teinte alors que l'udf
le rpr hésite sur la réponse à donner au
référendum le front national lui a pris
sa décision
un non franc et massif la campagne est
ouverte front national dénonce derrière
la propagande de paix et de fleurs qui
est présente est d'ores et déjà sur les
écrans de la télévision la réalité d'un
scrutin qui dans l'esprit de ses
promoteurs doit conduire inéluctablement
à l'indépendance de la nouvelle
calédonie une position claire pourtant
le front national est en pleine
réorganisation
yann piat la députée contestataires
n'avait pas fait le déplacement et
risquent aujourd'hui d'exclusion et puis
un poste de délégué général a été créé
il est confié à bruno mégret bruno
mégret qui passe pour être un modéré le
front national jean-marie le pen a bien
l'intention de poursuivre le
développement de son mouvement du
courant qu'il incarne dans l'esprit de
la campagne présidentielle
après le durcissement observée ces
derniers mois le front national tente
une opération de rééquilibrage qui avait
réussi au moment de la campagne de
l'élection présidentielle cette fois les
échéances ont aussi importante
référendum mais aussi élections
municipales et européennes au printemps
un nouveau revers après celui des
cantonales signifierait le retour du
front national dans la marginalité
oui après le front national le centre
national des indépendants le ceni
appelle également à voter non au
référendum estimant que la nature de la
question posée ne figure pas dans la
constitution comme pouvant être soumise
à référendum
enfin sur place à nouméa premier
incident après la signature de l'accord
entre messieurs tjibaou et la peur
depuis la signature des policiers se
sont heurté un groupe de jeunes dans le
centre de la ville d'après la police ces
jeunes mélanésiens se battaient entre
eux il ne s'agirait pas là d'un incident
de nature politique en france encore
fait divers fin d'une affaire sordide
celle de la mort de la petite ludivine 9
ans à clermont ferrand violée et tuée
par un jeune homme de 22 ans robert des
reculs par était hier est officiellement
inculpé aujourd'hui et qui reconnaît
être également l'auteur de cinq autres
agressions contre des fillettes
toujours à clermont ferrand à l'étranger
le principal point de préoccupation
aujourd'hui reste l'algérie
le gouvernement avait demandé aux
algériens de reprendre le travail
aujourd'hui tout en reconnaissant pour
la première fois que des manifestants et
des membres des forces de l'ordre
avaient été tués ces jours derniers eq
après alger l'agitation avait gagné
d'autres villes du pays comme oran au
téléphone notre envoyé spécial jack
berline et bien entendu l'armée a tiré
en l'air à l'est c'est toujours l'état
de siège
l'armée entre chaque ministère opposé au
principe on faire progresser partout
d'ailleurs la patrouille et les forces
anti émeutes sont toujours mobilisés la
situation semble calme aujourd'hui et
l'on remarque dans les rues des groupes
de dizaines de jeunes enfants et
attendant peut-être un signe pour que
tout recommence ailleurs fait la queue
devant les boulangeries
si la tension
oui en fin d'après-midi le calme était
vraiment précaire alger il y aurait de
nouveaux affrontements entre forces de
l'ordre et manifestants dans la banlieue
de la ville il y aurait d'autres morts
l'armée aurait ouvert le feu
premières déclarations du ministre
français des affaires étrangères
monsieur roland dumas sur ce sujet
reckitt actuellement en espagne
il a jugé la situation préoccupante
espérant que le calme allait revenir
prudence donc du côté diplomatique
français vis-à-vis du président algérien
monsieur de chadli et de son action
acteur depuis le début des événements au
milieu de la semaine on a beaucoup parlé
de la situation économique
as tu re de l'algérie pour comprendre
sachez que ce pays tire 90% de ses
ressources de son pétrole
il y a deux ans devant l'effondrement
des cours le président y un président
algérien chadli décide un plan
d'austérité est aujourd'hui les prix
chutent à nouveau le problème de
l'algérie c'est celui de tous les pays
pauvres qui produisent du pétrole face
aux autres producteurs plus riches
jean-pierre méthyle la maladie de
l'algérie porte un nom contre choc
pétrolier
le pétrole rapporté 13 milliards de
dollars voici sept ans aujourd'hui 4
milliards avec un dollar déprécier le
pouvoir d'achat de l'algérie a été
divisé par cinq
du coup les importations alimentaires
ont diminué de moitié tandis que les
impôts augmenté de 20% en trois ans il y
a lien direct entre des émeutes et le
prix du pétrole
la manifestation rend farizon politique
ceux ci étaient révélées j'ai avec
quelques mois j'avais laquelle j'étais
dans un pays avec l'afrique noire congo
réservés il est quelquefois les vrm les
faits c'est sur l'étudiant parce que les
routes avaient été coupées et ne pouvait
plus aller à l'école parce que les
recettes de l'état et le 7 juillet la
vessie donc elle le congolais
aujourd'hui l'algérien d'indonésiens de
vénézuéliens sont en train de payer
servir le citoyen ordinaire
ces pays c est en train de payer dans sa
vie privée à danser ni de chaque jour
dans son confort dans ces mêmes ses
besoins vitaux les in politique que je
considère comme complètement erroné le
mal qu'on puisse dire pratiqué par les
responsables d'autres pays au banc des
accusés les pays du golfe persique les
déshérités de l'opep leurs proches de
tirer des revenus énormes du pétrole
alors que ces pays sont sous peuplés
n'ont aucune dette
mais au contraire des avoirs financiers
partout dans le monde
aujourd'hui encore c'est le roi fahd
d'arabie saoudite qui tire les ficelles
sa politique produire à tout crin en vue
du grand marchandage
car le conflit en irak est terminée en
s'asseyant à la table des négociations
les deux belligérants vont redevenir
deux gros producteurs de pétrole
le clivage est maintenant beaucoup plus
nette entre des pays qui luttent pour
leur survie comme l'algérie l'indonésie
le nigeria le mexique ou des pays qui
veulent reconstruire leur économie
ravagée par la guerre comme l'irak il ya
d'un côté et d'autre des pays qui
continuent de raisonner en terme de
parts du marché comme les émirats arabes
unis le koweit ou l'arabie saoudite
il est maintenant très clair pour tous
que si les prix du pétrole ne se
stabilise pas un niveau réseau allemand
élevé plusieurs pays exportateurs pour
s'y trouvaient dans une très grande
difficulté le peps se rencontrera fin
octobre puis le 21 novembre
au menu le partage du marché
l'affrontement sera très très dur mais
pour les pays exemple comme l'algérie il
y va de leur survie
au chili les partisans du non au général
pinochet ont été privé de fête après
leur victoire électorale de mercredi
dernier en effet une grande
manifestation avait été organisée hier
soir dans les rues de la capitale
santiago mais les leaders de
l'opposition ne sont pas venus parler à
leurs partisans qui quelque peu
désemparés se sont accrochés avec la
police le ministre de l'intérieur
chilien précisant à cette occasion que
quel que soit le résultat des élections
lors devait continuer à régner comment
organiser cette victoire électorale
contre le régime militaire c'est tout le
problème posé aujourd'hui à l'opposition
chilienne sur place notre envoyé spécial
bernard b dès le début de l'après midi
qu'ils arrivaient par
il y ait dans ce parc au higgins en
plein centre de santiago pour célébrer
leur victoire
une fête organisée en catastrophe les
incidents se multipliaient dans la rue
depuis la publication des résultats du
plébiscite
il fallait donc essayer de canaliser
l'ardeur et la combativité des jeunes
surtout
d'où cette manifestation décidée
seulement 24 heures plus tôt au
programme de la musique mais pas de
discours politique
une autre preuve de l'embarras dans
lequel se trouve le dirigeant
d'opposition
d'autant qu'entre deux chansons c'est de
la foule préparez les slogans
je crois qu'après la victoire il incombe
aux forces armées d'écouter la voix du
peuple chilien
il incombe aussi à l'opposition
d'apporter une réponse unitaire à la
situation dans laquelle se trouve le
pays
en formant par exemple un gouvernement
d'unité nationale et on est à la
tonhalle des propos assez vagues sans
mot d'ordre très précis on a connu
ricardo lagos beaucoup plus combatifs et
comme pour mieux souligner cette gêne le
plus gros succès de l'après midi sera
cette phrase du nord
la chanson du ralliement de toute
l'opposition mais avant le plébiscite
à
quelques heures plus tard si les
chiliens se posait encore des questions
sur la signification du vote les gaz
lacrymogènes des carabiniers se charger
de dissiper l'ivresse de la victoire
on a l'impression que cette fête hier et
la déclaration de ricardo lagos n'ont
fait que traduire les troubles de
l'opposition en gros on a voté non au
général pinochet et aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas très bien quoi faire de cette
victoire
personne parmi les politiques ne se
hasarde à émettre une stratégie bien
définie
pourtant l'opposition devra faire très
vite si elle ne veut pas être débordée
par ses 4 millions de chiliens qui ont
d'abord voté pour le départ du général
pinochet
pour terminer ce journal
particulièrement chargée en actualité ce
samedi un anniversaire 35 ans c'est
l'âge de la patrouille acrobatique de
l'armée de l'air française
l'anniversaire aura lieu demain sur la
base de salon-de-provence dans le midi
les meetings aériens ont été
malheureusement pour cause de
catastrophe au centre de l'actualité cet
été et pour autant l'armée de l'air
française n'a pas renoncé à cette
commémoration avec toutes les mesures de
sécurité qui s'imposent et qui ont été
renforcées l'événement aura donc lieu
dimanche et en avant-première laurent
bouvier vous propose de suivre les
prouesses de ses pilotes vu de
l'intérieur comme si vous y étiez
regarder esprit d'équipé retrouvailles
espagnol portugais belges hollandais
avion de voltige avions de tous
a atomisé
rageant
je comprends dimension arrivé ce matin
plus de 150 avions se sont entraînés
dans l'après midi pour la présentation
de demain la série continue
j'ai chaud la combinaison opigez me
compris votre look litres j'aimerais que
cette instance ne s'arrête jamais fait
chez les colorer la patrouille italienne
première grande sortie en france depuis
l'accident de rammstein l'attention
folie sur un visage la concentration le
sérieux
six avions au lieu de neuf les souvenirs
plane dans sa journée qu'elle est pour
la patrouille france est très important
tous ne sont pas vraiment à se redresser
valon behrami une boue retenir sa
respiration tendre ses muscles garder
les yeux ouverts
le père est venu aider sans que tu viens
pour les pilotes ces retrouvailles ces
rencontres ces démonstrations sont la
preuve de leur maîtrise totale de la
voltige et de leur aptitude au combat
principales qualités
la rigueur le professionnalisme et un
entraînement quotidien qui permet à leur
contact de font sentir en sécurité
à
il avait confié
pour rien
rassurez-vous laurent bousses il n'avait
pas mal digéré même si c'était un peu
vert disons qu'il était un petit peu
contractées et ça se comprend
voici maintenant les résultats du tiercé
qui se courait cet après midi pour
gagner il fallait jouer le 4 le 8 et le
oui les rapports s'inscrire sur votre
écran il y avait un quarter également
vous ajoutez le 13 ses trois premiers
chiffres et vous gagnez un peu plus de
cinquante cinq mille francs de quoi
passer un excellent dimanche et pour
passer un excellent lundi une bonne
semaine prochaine voici les pronostics
de pirey de braise pour le tiercé de
demain à longchamp alors il y a vingt
partants vous allez voir s'inscrire les
favoris de pierrette brès le 7 le 5 le
12 le 8 le 9 le 13 le 6 et le 16
voilà ce journal est terminé merci de
l'avoir suivi l'actualité était
important mais passionnante tout de
suite après les prévisions météo avec
josé blanc lapierre ensuite michel
drucker et ses champs elysées avec ce
soir rambo en personne et puis un autre
rambo celui de l'information tout à
l'heure en fin de programme
c'est hervé claude qui vous présentera
le dernier journal quant à moi si vous
voulez bien je vous retrouverai demain à
13h au revoir bonne soirée à demain midi
à